ladies and gentlemen i'm drinking a
detox right now oh it's symbolic
for how
warner brothers is
flushing some things out of their system
in their dc
detox extended universe yeah guys the
dcu is continuing its trend of getting
us excited for their solo outings by
pumping up other characters
no there is no such thing as a true solo
outing any longer i'm actually pretty
excited to talk about this one today you
know enough cynical jokes aside here we
have some batgirl leaks going on this
means set photos rumor has a wb can be a
little bit uh particular how about some
photos being on the internet so
hopefully this video gets to live on so
we got some set photo leaks from the
batgirl set and a big confirmation for a
certain wonder boy all right so first
thing on the list we got a set photo
leak here of batgirl as you guys can see
it's leslie grace in a gcpd outfit who
would appear to have some red dye in her
hair looks like there's red dye i'm not
100 about that but
i would assume so and obviously she's
gonna be playing barbara gordon daughter
of commissioner gordon who will be
played by none other than jk simmons and
when it comes to what they're erasing
from the snyder verse and what they're
keeping from the snyder verse honestly
my my head just starts to hurt it really
i'm like i can't think about this too
much i see you wait for the movie to see
if they can explain it themselves just
the parts everyone agrees on
so yeah in case you guys haven't heard
obviously there are possible spoilers
here but the new justice league after
the events of the flash which is
essentially the dceu's version of
flashpoint dealing with multiverses
timelines and whatnot the new trilogy
will be comprised of batgirl
super girl and wonder woman with ben
affleck's batman saying tata and henry
cavill supposedly out as well even
though i am hearing rumors that they
could still keep him around for certain
supporting roles or cameos maybe to help
support supergirl along the way but
that's not what this video is about this
hbo max movie for the batgirl which i'm
still like why is this on hbo who will
to help promote the jesus
show yeah of course i'm supposed to also
have the gcpd show that's from within
the batman universe yeah and i know they
are filming this in glasgow where where
are they is the class go classical let's
go let's go
edinburgh they're filming that over
there where they also are filming the
batman which is just a place where you
know they didn't know like it'll be just
cheaper if we shoot here so i get that
you got a lot of historical looking
buildings right right but the batman and
this one is supposed to be michael
keaton's so uh all right whatever
let's not overthink this i guess that's
this whole thing is about overthinking
until they come out so this new hbo max
movie of the batgirl is initially going
to be set up
from the flash movie which will of
course have michael keaton and this
version of batgirl is going to be
trained by michael keaton's batman now
we don't have a new look at our suit yet
but for what i'm hearing it's supposed
to be comprised of like a mix between
the new 52 and the year one outfit a
little bit of black a little bit yellow
a little bit dark blue we don't know
what it looks like yet but i'm sure
it'll look badass but the main one
everyone is talking about of course the
main thing a new merle mural
see that beautiful girl they just
painted downtown it has this fantastic
looking outfit of batman and it's got
like the white eyes and many are hoping
this is like the new look of michael
keaton's bat suit especially with the
white eyes intact i feel like that's the
main thing we've been watching people
just love those
it took us so long to get here and now
we're already gone but i wouldn't be so
sure if this is the case because this
would have to be from a much earlier
point in time than when the flash movie
is taking place and when the batgirl
movie is taking place because obviously
michael keaton he's gonna be playing a
much older version of batman because the
guy's 120 but he looks 60.
you know it's perfect for your little
batman beyond nod because of the fact
that it's like a little bit withered the
paint is fading this has to be like
something that's been up for a long time
now so not sure what era this is taking
place in but it's got to be from the
earlier days of michael keaton's
adventures as batman and something that
nightwingology on twitter pointed out
and it seems to be the main thing people
are running with now the more i look at
it the more sure i am the mural on the
batgirl set lifted i don't know how to
pronounce this person's name so i'm
gonna say car andrews care andrews robin
from the 1970s variant of the robin 80th
anniversary special and yeah the more
you look at it it's like yeah that seems
like they directly lifted it is exactly
the same yeah the writing and all that
yeah this confirms a few things because
just a few days ago there were actors
being reported that were testing for the
role of robin people rumored like dylan
o'brien and i'm going to say that one
forget everyone else everyone else it's
just me
brian yeah or logan if not dylan o'brien
or men
gotta play aladdin oh yeah
that'd be fun i'm sure no one would get
upset
yeah why not let's see how this goes so
what this is indicating to me even more
so is that the rumors of michael
keaton's batman being the official
batman acting almost as if like the nick
fury for the dc eu soon to becoming more
and more true as time is going on so
like regarding snyder verse there was a
robin established in that world many
thought that that was the jason todd
outfit but zack snyder clarified that
that was actually dick grayson so at
least with this new iteration of the dc
eu we will have a an active live degree
synthetic that would be nicer nice i
like that sure yeah
it's funny because it seems like every
batman movie has wanted to have one to
some degree so few of them have achieved
that and and for them wiping out like
val kilmer and george clooney i think
it's funny that this movie can
potentially give us a new robin again
well i guess this is a little bit odd to
me about this and something that i don't
hear being brought up they've kind of
done a superman returns thing with the
michael keaton's batman world because
batman forever and batman and robin are
sequels to the michael keaton movies
they just replaced the actors
uh okay
they are yeah and it's just easy to
forget that that's a fact i know
people act like that's not effective
it's easy to put it into this
they just replaced him they had a robin
in those movies so i guess they're
completely erasing the events of batman
forever batman riding chris o'donnell
back why not man they had a robin you
bring him back old
grizzled bring back alicia silverstone
while you're at it this version of robin
that is trained is not the chris
o'donnell version obviously it does
bring up the question because you do
have michael keaton who is much older
now and by this point in his timeline
when he's playing batman i mean it might
not be like michael keaton's exact age
of what it is in real life which is 220.
he might be like i've been batman for
like 30 years
so could be a young robin that has been
trained but he also could be nightwing
and a lot of you guys might not know
this but nightwing is actually my
favorite character from the batman
universe like outside of batman it's
nightwing so within dc it's him and in
terms of reading comics he was the one i
grew up on the most was nightwing so
i've been really wanting a nightwing
movie for quite some time i know chris
mckay the director of the lego batman
movie right lego batman right he
hasn't had has had a nightwing movie in
development for ages so it's definitely
going to happen
okay if they have dick grayson
is this version of dick grayson he has
to eventually become nightwing and is
this version of nightwing gonna be the
one chris mckay is working on or is that
chris mckay one completely scrapped at
this point maybe he's already nightwing
because if you look at the mural and how
it looks like it's it's been painted a
while ago and it's of a more classic
looking batman and robin maybe that is
from a while ago when he was actually a
kid and he has since moved on to
becoming nightwing in the present of
this movie if anything this could at
least plant the seeds for nightwing
which could go exclusively on the mobile
app for hbo that's right the only on
mobile though you can't watch it on your
tv or okay forget it but it could plant
the scenes today you could have like
introduced bloodhaven you could just
flat out introduce nightwing you know
barbara gordon and dick grayson had of
course have their romantic
tinglings uh you could have you know the
introduction of blockbuster in some way
there's there's a lot of things you
could do the idea of having dick grayson
be active alive and definitely existing
like if you're gonna have batgirl you
gotta have the presence of robin really
the question is is like what is gonna be
the tone of this robin when he is
officially introduced hey i mean
speculation at least i saw grace
randolph tweet saying that this is gonna
set up a robin appearance that will then
shoot into a nightwing movie and that
sounds like what they're kind of doing
with this whole flash situation we're
going to use this as a jumping off point
for all of our new franchises for the
bat family yeah and and i guess any
other dc eu super girl etc that's also
coming down the pike yeah that's true
well guys uh here we are today with this
robin news what did you all think leave
your thoughts down below you can
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button are you excited for robin have
your thoughts changed on the flash at
all are you excited at all for a batgirl
what are you looking for brendan fraser
from the dc
razor people forget brandon pager is
already in the dc properties
finally i'm like guys he's been around
for like three seasons three seasons
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below we'll catch you soon